last thing i want to talk about is the
work that
builds upon this interactive proof ideas
and this argumentization ideas and using
polynomials using algebra
that has to do with np-hardness of
approximations so so far we talked about
decision problems
and we talked about threesat as
np-complete problems so it's
very difficult to tell satisfiable
formulas from unsatisfiable formulas
but in real life we often talk about
uh approximation algorithms uh which
don't find the optimal solution to some
optimization problem but only
approximately optimal to some
factor approximations and it would like
to
it would be nice to say something about
the difficulty of solving
those natural optimization problems
approximately even
and that's exactly what we can do using
the ideas
of probabilistically checkable proofs
that i'm going to talk about next
so let me start with our good old friend
free satisfiability we're given 3cnf5
on m clauses natural question to ask
is how many clauses of phi can they
satisfy simultaneously
okay one obvious answer is well if phi
is satisfiable then all m clauses can be
satisfied simultaneously
and if i is not satisfiable that then
fewer than m clauses can be satisfied
simultaneously
that's correct but not this satisfying
uh forgive me my pun
so if the formula is not satisfiable
then the number of clauses that can be
simultaneously satisfied
obviously must be strictly less than m
the total number of clauses
how much smaller than m can it be well
we're gonna
show that
for any formula phi satisfiable or
unsatisfiable
it's always possible to satisfy at least
seven eighth
fraction of the clauses
okay and this is a very simple argument
that i will
show you that's a fact you can always
satisfy
at least seven eighth of m clauses in a
given collection of m clauses
and the proof is by probabilistic method
you look at the particular clause on
three literals like this one in the
example
and if you think about random assignment
that you pick
uniformly the probability that this
clause is satisfied will be
exactly one minus one over eight one
over eight is the probability that the
clause is
not satisfied you really need to be
unlucky and
pick x i to be zero x j to be one
and x k to be zero uh only one choice
out of eight
possibilities for these three literals
will make the clause false
so with probability one minus one over
eight which is seven eight this clause
will be
true so the expected number of satisfied
clauses if you pick a random assignment
by simple argument is 7 8 times
m because it's each clause is satisfied
with probability 7
8 and clauses the expected number of
satisfied ones is seven eight times
m and by probabilistic argument if the
expectation is
seven eight over m then there must be at
least one
assignment which satisfies at least
seven eight
times m clauses okay
so we tightened a little bit um
the possibilities for unsatisfiable
formulas in terms of
how many uh simultaneously satisfiable
satisfied clauses they can have
so we know that um unsatisfiable clause
unsatisfiable formulas uh live somewhere
around
here uh they have the number of
simultaneously satisfied clauses
somewhere between 7 8 m and strictly
less than
m but they can't be anywhere in this
range as far as we know
can we somehow push
the number of satisfied clauses closer
to the left
edge of this interval make them closer
to 7 8
times m and the answer is yes
and that's possible thanks to this
optimal result due to johan hostet from
around 1997 which
can be viewed as an equivalent statement
of the pcp
theorem pcp theorem of course is a
it's a work of many people um i'm not
giving the history of the results here
i'm just stating one particular way of
uh
stating the pcp theorem uh with
three cnfs due to hosted
so the statement is the following fix
some constant epsilon bigger than zero
okay like one over ten then
there exists a polynomial time reduction
from three suck to three sat
sounds a bit suspicious why do you need
to reduce threes out of three sat well
because the conditions will be different
from the usual reduction that we had
seen before in the context of np
completeness
so the reduction r will be the following
it will take
a 3c and f5 and will map it to another
3cnf
r of phi satisfying the following two
conditions
if the original formula 5 was
satisfiable then the new
formula rfi will also be satisfiable
more interestingly if the original
formula 5 was not satisfiable
then the new formula r of phi will be
at most seven eighth plus epsilon
satisfiable
meaning that at most seven eight plus
epsilon fraction of the clauses
of the formula r of phi can be
simultaneously satisfied
okay so we basically take the formula
phi
and transform it into a new for three
cnf formula
such that if the formula was satisfiable
the number of satisfied clauses will
stay on the right hand side
here but if the formula was
unsatisfiable before
the new formula will have the number of
satisfying assignments
living somewhere on the left side of the
interval
7 8 plus epsilon times m okay and there
will be
nothing in between here so we have a gap
between the number of clauses that can
be simultaneously satisfied
as a corollary of this result we can say
that
it's np hard to distinguish satisfiable
freesat formulas
from seven eight plus epsilon
satisfiable ones
where seven eight plus epsilon
satisfiable are exactly those
where you can satisfy seven eighth plus
epsilon fraction of clauses
and in turn this can be interpreted as
saying that
an optimization problem marks three sat
which asks given a formula uh find
the maximum number of clauses that can
be simultaneously satisfied since
optimization problem
maximize the number of causes
simultaneously satisfied that this
optimization problem is and be hard to
approximate
c approximate where c
therefore approximation factor is eight
seven
plus epsilon which is tight because of
this
probabilistic argument argument
probabilistic argument that i mentioned
earlier
for completeness i state what it means
for
a problem optimization problem like maxa
to be c approximated
basically means that you need to find
the value of v which
is at most the optimal value which is
the maximum number of satisfying
assignments
optifi but at least one over c
fraction of the optimal value okay
so 1 over c in in case c is 8 7
plus epsilon is going to be roughly 7 8
plus x
finally another way we can use this
uh reduction from freestyle to threesat
in hosted's result is to
think about the following generalization
or refinement
of the gain between the prover and the
way fire that we defined when it
defined the empty problems to begin with
so think of the following refinement
you have proven very fire
we have three cnf formula phi which is
a common input to the prover and the
verifier
the prover will send some
bit string of polymer aluminium bits t
to the verifier and in the usual
definition
of np the way fire will just take this
assignment
plug it into the formula phi and check
if formula fire is satisfiable
that would involve looking at the entire
assignment
y1 through yt we don't want to do that
our verifier will be very lazy
it will randomly select some collection
of at most
three bits in the string y
and check that those bits satisfy some
constraints
and with very good probability we'll
catch
incorrect proof and correct witness that
the approval will send to the verifier
so more precisely here's what's going to
happen the verifier on input phi
will construct the new 3cnf psi
which is r of phi where r
is the reduction from hostile's theorem
this constructed psi will have some t
number of variables polynomial mini and
some
m polynomial number of clauses
then the verifier will pick a random
clause
out of this m ones call it ci
and will accept if and only if
this clause c sub i is satisfied
by the corresponding three bits from the
bit string
y okay so the verifier
will randomly select a clause using
small amount of randomness about log n
bits of randomness because there are
only polynomial clauses
and then we'll only look at the proof
sent by the prover in three locations
corresponding to the variables mentions
mentioned in the clauses of i
and accept if those three bits
in the proof y satisfied that chosen
randomly closed c sub i
and the properties we get from this is
that if phi
was satisfiable then there exists a
proof
y sent by the prover that the way fire
will consult
using its randomly chosen locations to
check
and the way fire will accept with
probability one because
if i was satisfiable the new formula r05
will also be satisfiable so
if the prover is honest and will send
the correct satisfying assignments every
clause chosen by the verifier will be
satisfied
on the other hand if the formula 5 is
not satisfiable
then no matter what assignment
prover sends to the verifier
the fraction of clauses that can be
simultaneously satisfied
in this formula r of phi is going to be
at most 7
8 parts epsilon so if the verifier picks
a clause at random
the probability that it he gets a
satisfied clause
is at most 7 8 plus epsilon so with
probability
1 minus that with probability about one
over eight the way
fire will see a clause which is not
satisfied and will reject
okay so a verifier can be lazy can
can only read small number of free bits
from the proof
it will have to be randomized to pick
which position to pick by
using randomness and then it can
check if the proof was good or not this
is quite amazing
that you don't need to read the entire
satisfying assignment of the formula
but if you massage the formulas
appropriately then
you can only it's a sufficient for you
to read
uh on the constant number of three bits
of the new proof
for the new formula and have pretty good
confidence
in accepting uh correct witnesses
correct proofs and with decent constant
probability rejecting incorrect proofs
with very little work done
and that concludes this part of the
online tutorial
and we'll continue with more stuff to
talk about
in the online part during the bootcamp